buenos días cómo están qué tal
voy a compartirles el episodio de la
vida de dos mujeres
emilia es una niña que vivía en huaraz
lamentablemente tuvo que dejar el
colegio por dedicarse a trabajar
trabajar significaba para ella apoyar a
su familia y a sus hermanos
como muchas niñas de su época
lamentablemente estaba designada
está bien estaba designada a trabajar oa
vincularse con pequeños oficios que la
obligaban a ayudar a sus hermanos ya su
madre como se los había comentado
cuando era adolescente fue obligada a
vivir con un nombre mayor que la
maltrataba y abusaba sexualmente de ella
mariana es una niña que vive en lima es
brillante confía mucho en sí misma ya
sabes de esas que quieren conquistar el
mundo
mariana si tuve la oportunidad de
terminar el colegio la universidad ya
está de conseguir un gran empleo
sin embargo cuando era adolescente fue
víctima de violación sexual y este hecho
la compañía durante mucho tiempo como un
fantasma un fantasma que venía
disfrazado de depresión de baja
autoestima hasta de ataques de pánico
porque les comparto estas historias
porque las conozco tan de cerca
emilia es mi abuela y mariana soy yo
sin embargo la vida continúa
qué pasó con mi abuela después micro a
lima estaba solita no conocía
absolutamente a nadie no tenía contactos
no tenía ninguna familia en lima que la
pudiera [ __ ] sin embargo decidió dar un
paso adelante ya saben cuando rompes ese
umbral y confías en ti misma
poco después consiguió trabajo a pesar
de sufrir discriminación por su origen y
por no obtener educación
poco después formó una familia y tenía
algo muy en claro tenía que poner comida
sobre la mesa y eso significaba tener un
buen trabajo
sin embargo al no contar con educación
que le permitiera conseguir un buen
trabajo y mejores oportunidades sabía
que su techo era completamente limitado
y mi abuela empezó a estudiar con dos
hijos a cuestas según lo que me comenta
mi mamá y lo que me comentaba ya también
era la mejor de su clase
y hasta recibía diplomas
luego como un gran símbolo de esfuerzo
de punta y de trabajo mi abuela
consiguió comprarse un puesto en el
mercado construir su propia casa y hasta
darle educación a sus hijos y para mí
este es el más claro ejemplo de
transformación personal
qué pasa conmigo
les soy sincera ocultar un hecho como
esto como lo que me pasó no es nada
sencillo sin embargo trate de encubrir
lo tratar de como que no pasará sin
embargo esas preguntas de que por qué me
pasó a mí porque nunca se sancionó el
culpable porque yo
por mi trabajo tuve y tengo la
oportunidad de conocer a muchas mujeres
que siendo niñas le pasó lo mismo que a
mí
me tomo casi 18 años volver a hablar del
tema
saber que todos estos puntos y cada una
de las cosas que me habían pasado me
trajeron hasta aquí
tuve mucho mucho mucho miedo no se los
voy a mentir
sin embargo al igual que mi abuela sabía
que tenía que dar un paso hacia adelante
sabía que tenía que avanzar
y lo hice
consulte a expertos me tomo casi un año
y medio sentarme en mi escritorio y
ponerme a diseñar algo yo estaba
completamente segura que todo lo que me
había pasado era un propósito tenía que
estar tenía que hacer algo
consulte a expertos e investigue qué
cosa podría hacer yo para ayudar a otras
niñas a que no les pasa exactamente lo
mismo que a mí y es ahí donde empezó
toda esta magia
fundé la organización
fundé la organización niña valiente niño
valiente es un programa de formación
dirigido a niñas y adolescentes con el
propósito de ayudarlas y vincularlas a
cumplir sus metas y sus objetivos
una de las principales líneas de
acciones de nuestro programa es la
formación a través de la formación
nosotros trabajamos con ellas
habilidades blandas salud derechos y el
poder ambiente económico
en la inspiración nuestras niñas pueden
conocer en las embajadoras mujeres
líderes país que están construyendo a
través de sus trabajos sus
emprendimientos un mejor futuro para
ellas para sus familias y para todo lo
que ellas puedan realizar es increíble
que a través de nuestro programa y a
través de esta importante línea de
acción nuestras niñas puedan conocer a
bomberas pilotas quieren estás dueñas de
negocio y sepan que nada es imposible y
sobre todo que una mujer lo está
haciendo
en toma de acción nosotros vinculamos a
nuestras niñas a programas de
voluntariado porque es importante que
ellas sepan que allá afuera del colegio
y de sus casas ocurre otra realidad
ocurre en otras cosas y quiero detenerme
un momentito aquí en nuestro país una
niña que vive en el círculo de la
pobreza
una niña que vive en el círculo de la
pobreza de una manera u otra tiende a
repetirlo en sus próximas generaciones
es decir ella no podrá o no se sentirá
inspirada y empoderada para educar a sus
hijas y de esa manera se va a repetir el
círculo de la pobreza
en la zona andina de nuestro perú la
mayoría de las niñas no culminan la edad
a una edad temprana o a una edad
oportuna la secundaria
la reniec en el 2015 registró 1538 casos
de mujeres que habían acudido a su
institución para registrar a sus hijas
el promedio de edad de estas mujeres era
entre los 11 y 14 años es decir niñas
que estaban siendo mamás en la gran
mayoría de estos casos estas niñas
habían sido madres producto de una
violación
es importante que nuestras niñas puedan
ser
tratadas como adultas y que puedan
incluirse en las leyes políticas y
presupuesto de nuestro país con la misma
importancia que los adultos
si les cuento todo esto es porque hoy he
podido hablar todos los puntos de mi
vida y sé que niña valiente no es solo
una empresa más es mi propósito de vida
para mí fue sumamente importante mirar
hacia atrás reconocer mi dolor reconocer
mi miedo saber que todo este todo lo que
había pasado realmente me podría llevar
a algún lado
fue importante mirar hacia los lados
para saber quién tenía en ese momento mi
familia mis mentores mis amigos
y mirar hacia el frente me hizo humilde
porque sé
lo que es y lo que se siente estar al
otro lado
[Aplausos]
ella es mi abuela
y yo por ella sé que estoy aquí y sé que
le estoy compartiendo todo esto
al marcharse mi abuela me regaló un
dulce beso de amor
hoy reconozco mi propósito y sé que
detrás de cada gran mujer hay una niña
valiente gracias
[Aplausos]